still
he can't knock me down because i'm
switching ground vector
he's pushing and then hook your
projection
you're gonna i know you're gonna get
tired just keep playing he's pushing but
moving moving changing
pushing push round vector
whoa changing vector boom
i looked at my foot so you can see
that it's a single point
he's pushing it's on the back foot boom
i move it over on the other foot boom
[Music]
really hard push push push push push
your harness is your last one
push
i'm trying to create a separation so
right now we're coming together and then
he's gonna go back out
okay that's the separation uh
the obvious way is to just put push your
mouth push it up
okay
way is his he's he's it's not me pushing
on him
he's pushing on the ground okay so he's
pushing
he's pushing on the ground pushing on
the ground
and there's things that that um
you can't that you see the difference
because i'm not pushing on him
um he can't go around me so when i go to
when i'm going to push on him
he can go he can spin around he can spin
around that thing
i'm going to push on him and he just
spins around on
but when when he's pushing on me that
the the point where
where he's pushing on me because the
anchor so he's going to try to
turn around that elbow
all right
so something else is happening okay
some other things you'll see like uh
obviously
you can see that the tension in my body
as i do that he's pushing really hard
really hard
all you can see that is very relaxed
nice very very pretty hard too short
it's very relaxed very relaxing
but not here
it's it's him rebounding off the rock
so i'm just changing
where my ground vector is
[Music]
so
relax push push your hardest push your
heart push your heart
push your heart it actually gets easier
for me the harder you push
okay when you do the key on that that's
what you're doing so
you have a one cross lateral extension
and
ground vector and then the technique is
telling you to change it
okay or you're doing the keyhole and
you're doing it doing it inside the
technique
nothing changes nothing changes
so don't start trying to pull his hand
technique happens inside inside the head
still changing vectors
okay